brandon bilac makes his first home start
just his second start of his career and
he will use that defense behind him
tonight to try and continue where he
left off last start hit up the middle
brakeman cuts it off throws high
and
dickerson's going to be aboard
tyler anderson's on the mound for the
san francisco giants
astros have faced him a couple of times
in
their careers only two games started
against the astros one good one not very
good reddick with a ball to the wall in
right field he is hustling to second
base and josh reddick slides in safely
with a double he is now hitting nine of
his last 10 starts so here's flores
there's a swing and there's a drive hit
deep into left center field way back
there and into the crawford boxes
goodbye
fourth home run of the season for
willmar flores he found the crawford
boxes and it is one to nothing giants
he shoots one into center field and it's
going to fall for a hit
so slater he's got that little magic
wand where you just don't hit it perfect
you hit it a little bit towards the end
of the back
tucker sends one to center field
yustrepski on the move still on the move
diving attempt it's in play tucker's
thinking about three he's gonna go for
third and he will get there kyle tucker
and triple with one out in the second
that's his second career triple but he
smiled more than twice yes
since then this ball is ripped to the
left field for an rbi base hit maldonado
drives in tucker maldi thinking about
two as he ties the game at one and he'll
get in there with a sliding double
triple followed by a double to not this
game
maldonado with the rbi double altuve
with a walk
into center field falling quickly and
that is going to be down for a hit in
the score maldonado the ball is loose
around third comes out two bay he's
gonna score reddick heading to third he
will make the final out there but the
astros add two runs and now lead it
three to one
[Music]
yostrepski a great effort couldn't quite
come up with that ball and the astros
scored two
tyler anderson facing alex bregman for
the second time bregman flied out to
center his first time up alex sends one
deep to left field headed towards the
crawford boxes and gone
alex bregman hits his fourth home run of
the year and the astros now lead 4-1
he lines this one into left field for a
base hit
sitting on that first pitch breaking
ball good or bad
so here's dickerson who also represents
the possible tying run he has
singled and popped out to third three
infielders stacked up on the right side
there's a swing and a ground ball into
the
middle the opening between the two
infielders and into right center field a
base hit
trump around third he scores and it's
now four to two or difference on his
curveball
julie doesn't care about velocity as he
serves one into left field past evan
longoria that'll be a base hit for
euless one for three on the ground base
hit carlos correa the other way he's
been doing that well this year using the
right side of the infield he'll clap his
hands at that ball in the center
yustrepski started back now he has to
come in he's not going to get there that
ball drops in it fooled you stremski off
the bat and it drops in for tucker's
second hit of the night pitch on the way
and that's grounded left side fielded by
the third baseman longori he steps on
third now throws to the catcher trump
who tags guriel as julie was trying to
get in a rundown could not so two outs
with two men on for straw now the three
one
and that's bounced right side pass belt
and into right field for a base hit
tucker around third and coming home to
throw to the plate by slaters up the
first baseline tucker scores down to
third goes maldonado it's an rbi single
for miles straw and the astros lead is
five to two much needed run for the
astros here there goes straw in the
first pitch now two main lines one to
right field that'll score another run
straw easily gets in the third where he
will hold up jose altuve and rbi singles
now six to two well hunter pence is
gonna hit this is where it all started
for hunter pence
pence goes the other way hit pretty well
it is out of here
hence goes the other way and we
got a ball game all of a sudden it's a
six to five ball game now
here's the one-two pitch
swing and there's a line drive into
right center field base hit
the second is just he turns the corner
he's digging for third and he'll make it
there without a throw
hunter pence
with another base head man it has to
feel good for the veteran possible tying
run is at third base the possible go
ahead run at first base
playing darren ruff to pull get on the
ground in a base hit
and this game is tied
off the bat
it looked like well
is it a hit or is it going to be a
double play to end the game outhouser
castle there was no in between there it
finds a hole and we got a brand new ball
game
slater lines it to right he's got
another hit flores will stop at third
and the giants have runners at the
corners so now it's crawford
up the middle and a base hit
coming in to score as flores
the giants take the lead
moving down to second goes slater
crawford with the rbi single well now
you got to face the left-handed hitting
kyle tucker 0-2
got him and that's the ball game
how about that the giants
were done in this game until hunter
pence gets a pinch
three-run home run
and then
the bullpen comes through and for tyler
rogers he picks up his first
career
save